YouTuberたるもの
何が大切かと言うと
そう、カメラ📷なんです!!
たぶんねえ、やっぱり...
美しく見られたいんですよ✨
やっぱり映像なんでえ、YouTube
如何に美しい映像を
皆さんにお届けできるかと言うことでぇ
まあ、僕も最初はね
なんか、んん
すごい安っぽいビデオカメラYouTubeをはじめて
ミラーレス一眼と言うね
背景がぼけるぅ
美しい映像に
んん～
みとれてえ
やっぱでもなんか
一眼だったらなあ
この、商品見せてるときに
自分の顔にピントが合って
この商品がぼけちゃうからな
ちょとビデオカメラの方がいいかなあとおもったから
ビデオカメラに戻って
そんでさらに、まあ結局やっぱり
綺麗な映像が一番いいし
自分もこうカッコよく😎映せるかなと言うことで
今あ、一眼レフを使ってるわけなんですけれどもぉ
今使ってるビデオカメラ
EOS80Dってやつで
結構まあそこそこ
・・・・・
綺麗に撮れてると思うんですけれども
これをつかってね
もうたぶん、一年ぐらいかな...
どれ、え、どれ位たったっけ
スゥ↑
まあ、さらなるステップアップを目指して
ちょっと.....
カメラを変えようと思いまして。
はいこちら
カメラでこの大きさですよｗ
はい新しいビデオカメラを買ってきました
でかい！
ええ、値段が
56万円です..........
(チャリーン★)
ごめん
ごめん！
(ドンッ！)
ほんとにごめん！
開封の儀は出来ない・・・
普通に開けます
でかい！
あ！あ！ああ♡
もおなんか、ってかでかいなあ
カメラ以外のもはいってますねえ
まとめてなんか色々買ったんでした
ああ！
今回のカメラは本当に慎重に使わないといけないので
バックを買いました
あぁ、あぁ↓
こっちが本体です(ドンッ！)
このカメラ僕ずっとほしいなと思ってたんですけども
まあ、流石になんか値段も値段だしい、
まあ、買わねえなとおもったんですけども
そろそろステップアップしてもいい時期なのかなと
思いまして、買いました
はいこちら
EOS　C100　Mark　Ⅱ
みんなわかるかｈっ？
C100ですよ？
瀬戸さんとかが買ってるカメラを
ようやく私もてにいれれたという話なんですけれど
(カサカサ)
なにこれ
あ、レンズ、レンズカバー
バッテリーチャージャー
これなんか、あの＆＄＃
な、なんで二つもある？
わかんない×１
わかんない×２
わかんない×３
わかんない×４
わかんない×５
わかんない！
バッテリー
帽子
本体
これがレンズですね
なかなか物が多いな
まあとりあえず、このカメラを日常的に使うかどうかは
また別なんですけれども
とりあえずこういうしっかりとした
ビデオカメラを一台僕は欲しかった
というわけで今回買わせていただきまし・・・た
うわぁ、うわぁぁ
これすげえな
うわぁ、かっこいいなあ
うわ、もうなんかやばいな
もう、なんかにぎるグリップがもうちがう
もう完全にビデオ撮る用なんで
赤いボタンをぽちっと押せば録画が出来ると・・・
あーー
きたわ
はい、こんな感じになってしまいました
あぁ、ついちゃったついちゃった
いやもう、逆にこっちからじゃあ伝わんないであろう
この綺麗さ
どれだっけな・・
あぁ、ぐにゃあん！
うう
やばばやばばん
ABABA
BA
はい、というわけで
ちょっとまじで
いかつくてちょっと怖い感じもするんですけどもお
もうなんか、１０００メダー
これ６０なのかなあ？
６０だなあ
OK、俺の好きな設定にしました
はい、と言うわけで
メインカメラを切り替える気がします
たぶん次からこれでとるのかな
わかんないですけど
せっかく綺麗な映像が撮れるので
なんか動画とってみようと思います
どうぞ！
(犬の糞お断り)
(ビシッ！)
(キラン✨)
(ぬん)
(いつものBGM)
(謎の空気)
クスッ